Do you believe in aliens?
I'm assuming they mean extra terrestrial aliens.
Yeah.
I assume you mean that I,
my opinion on aliens is that I'm sure in this vast unknown world and universe
there is likely to be other life forms that have some level of intelligence.
Interesting.
How sure.
On a scale from one to 10 how sure you are.
Obviously you can't be tagged very
um,
over five but well actually when you take the entire universe yeah.
Which is so massive,
we can barely even comprehend it.
The chances are decent that there is some other,
some how intelligent life form out there and you almost,
I mean you kind of have to ask wait like at this very time,
but then when you think about it there's really no time in a way.
Like that's kind of relative to so in the whole existence would you say what
nine are you level nine?
Sure.
Isn't that nice?
That's matter of opinion.
Don't know.
I think nine I think like 9.0 so you're a believer.
Yeah,
I'm a believer.
I would be vast.
Like if said some wizard guy was like,
okay,
you get to make a bet.
Do you think there is or isn't?
I know the answer.
You do think there is or isn't,
you know the wizard be proof of concept right there.
Unless you're talking to it anyway.
What if he was the guy from the future?
Okay.
And somehow figured it out.
I Dunno.
They map the whole universe.
I don't know.
Whatever.
I would bet.
Oh,
the cost is your life too,
by the way.
Like you have to make a bed,
you have to make a choice and you,
if you get it right,
you live,
you get it wrong,
you die.
I would would bet.
Yes,
I would bet.
Yes.
Yeah.
The thing is is you would also,
it'd be interesting to have a scientists or talk to a scientist about the
probability of human life.
Like how credibly
tiny,
minuscule,
like all the little things that had to happen for us to end up here and it's
okay for them to have them again.
Oh yeah.
It happened again.
So,
but then again,
you,
you compare that to the unknown world,
this universe that is so large,
it's been comprehensible.
The chances are it's happened somewhere else.
And even,
and just,
and that's in a way,
a different point where it's like,
you know,
what would it take to,
to make humans and wind up being humans?
If you look at it backwards,
it seems really like,
oh my gosh,
this is this crazy like,
you know,
almost impossible.
Yeah.
Miracle kind of thing.
But you,
you can say that with everyday thing if you look at it backwards.
So like let's say I had,
um,
like the Lego's,
right?
Okay.
We had this big bucket of Legos.
It was more the,
you know,
it's one of those big plastic tubs full of years and years and years of Lego
sets.
And there's all in there.
If I were to take that to full legos and fucking
tore it out on the ground on a marble surface.
So they scatter everywhere and then it'll,
you know,
when they all settle,
it'll be a little pattern,
right?
Legos,
various colors,
shapes,
sizes,
all kinds,
different places,
spaces.
And to take that exact pattern down to the nanometre,
that exact pattern and be like,
this is the most special pattern in the entire world ever in existence.
This one is,
there is no way anyone ever,
ever,
ever could recreate this exact pattern down to the nano meter.
It's impossible.
That's why this pattern is so special,
but it's just one of many potential eventualities,
probably infinite.
You know,
and when you end up at something and then say,
okay,
that what we happen to end up as is special it,
that's looking at it backwards.
Like I said,
so it's like the lottery winner.
You know the guy who wins the lottery,
you,
it's like,
oh my gosh,
I'm so special.
I want to let know freaking if I took a ping pong ball and I saw in,
I had a mosh pit of 1 million people.
If one ping pong ball,
I throw it in the mosh pit and then somebody catches it.
Oh my gosh,
I'm so special.
Breast,
someone's gonna get it.
Someone's going to get the ping pong ball.
That's affirmative.
Yeah.
So it doesn't make it necessarily special unless you look at it backwards.
You know,
if that guy's like,
I'm going to go into another one.
The other alien life form could be something that we could barely even imagine
of what it's like.
And that's that.
That probability wise is what it is.
Or it's going to be something like so small and but it,
if it's like more a superior intelligence,
it's going to be something we don't recognize the same way.
Like if you have a caterpillar on a leaf and I see it from 10 yards away,
oh,
I see that little cow caterpillar rate right there.
Hey Caterpillar yelling at it.
You know,
the vibration from my voice are hitting it.
It got up into the capitol.
The capitol has no idea that you even exist.
I don't even know what a human is.
Doesn't know about your problems,
doesn't know about your podcast,
you know.
Meanwhile,
you know a lot about your podcasts.
You know,
listen to the podcast.
I can say with a fair amount of,
and again,
I don't know,
maybe he does.
I don't know.
He has big butterfly plans for the future.
Jocko.
Next question.
How can I incur bro?
We can talk more about the aliens,
aliens or Legos.
I'm telling you they go patterns cause you know when people see you at foes,
they go straight to that's an alien.
Even though it's an unidentified,
you can't do that.
Remember I was telling you that kid's book ideas.
Yeah,
you did.
Tell me about that.
Tell me again.
Either it goes deeper than that telling you.
Telling me
actually,
it's more about the flaws of all people consider or regarding liens potentially.